[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
discuter débattre et réfléchir sur les
enjeux qui font l'actualité alors depuis
le 1er janvier la nouvelle baisse de la
taxe d'habitation concerne les 20% de
ménages les plus aisés du territoire
français 80% des foyers ne sont plus
concernés depuis l'automne dernier selon
bercy cette surpression aurait permis à
ces 22 millions de foyers d'économiser
en moyenne 590 euros
la taxe d'habitation est amené à
disparaître totalement 2023 pour les
résidences principales
au-delà de l'aspect économique elle
aussi qu'elle est aussi l'impact pour
les collectivités on en parle avec nos
deux invités en plateau avec nous
grégory gressier le maire de maurepas
bonsoir bonsoir et en visio pascal
berteaud ni maître de conférences en
droit public et directrice du
laboratoire vip de la faculté de droit
de l'ue vers l'université de versailles
saint quentin
bonsoir bonsoir et puis devait être avec
nous en plateau jean noël barrot député
de la 2e circonscription des yvelines et
vice président de la commission des
finances il a été retenu par un on
appelle ainsi un impératif alors la
réforme de la taxe d'habitation est
annoncée par emmanuel macron lors de la
campagne électorale de 2010 est elle est
modifiée par la loi de finances 2010 8
pascal bertoni cette taxe d'habitation
telle qu'on la connaît elle est née de
la réforme de la fiscalité directe
locale mise en place depuis 1974 comment
est ce qu'elle est accueilli à l'époque
par les particuliers et les
collectivités
alors j'ai j'avoue que j'ai pas bien
compris la question mais je pense que
vous voulez parler de l'histoire un peu
de patience
a été accueillie mais bon elle est mise
en place le problème c'est qu'en réalité
les très anciennes cette taxe
contrairement à ce qu'on pense sa
dénomination actuelle et peut-être de 74
mais en réalité ses débuts d'impôt de la
révolution
ça faisait partie des quatre ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque les quatre vieilles
et ça explique d'ailleurs pourquoi elle
est inadaptée
parce que là l'époque elle a été conçue
inciter les impôts de départ donc elle a
été conçue en réalité selon les données
économiques et sociales de l'époque donc
l'époque il n'y avait pas d'
administration fiscales telles qu'on les
cocktails qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui
la possibilité de contrôler donc le plus
simple finalement c'était 2-2 d'asseoir
les récits impôts sur sur les valeurs
locatives sur la terre puisque à
l'époque seule la terre était importante
ya pas eu il y avait pas encore la
révolution industrielle est alors en
fait elle a décroché c'est pas que ce
local ont décroché progressivement en la
première notamment la taxe d'habitation
elle décroché avec la fiscalité des pas
en 1917
on a créé un coup sûr mon mieux et
progressivement toutes les pages sont
devenus des taxes locales
alors cette histoire en fait elle est
importante pourquoi parce que elle
explique pourquoi finalement elle est
inadaptée à notre à notre époque puisque
maintenant on a une administration
fiscale qui est capable de
de contrôler etc je ne suis pas sûr que
politiquement elle soit réformable pour
ces raisons là parce que dès qu'on fait
d'un jeune fils car c'est pas pour les
quarts mais c'est également vrai pour
pour les collectivités locales et
surtout pour les collectivités locales
il ya des perdants étaient les gagnants
et les gagnants fourmillements et les
perdants sont sont rarement satisfait on
a tenté un régulièrement de réévaluer
les bases parce qu'en fait le problème
de la taxe d'habitation
c'est qu'elle est certaine inégalité
entre les contribuables puissent quand
y'a pas que bienvenu en tient compte
vous pouvez les appeler comment elle est
calculée cette taxe d'habitation
parce que pour justifier sa suppression
le ministère de la cohésion indique
qu'elle est inéquitable
elle est calculée sur quoi finalement
elle est calculée sur des valeurs
locatives théorique qui correspond pas
alors que ce sont des valeurs locatives
qui ont été définies en 1970 donc c'est
inéquitable pourquoi parce que comme les
bases ont été très peu réévalué bien les
logements anciens par exemple sont moins
taxés que les logements nouveaux et donc
dès lors qu'on achète un appartement ou
une maison là où on est on est beaucoup
plus taxé que que des logements très
ancien et c'est le problème le vrai
problème de la
la taxe d'habitation comme la taxe
foncière puisque les bases sont
identiques
c'est la mise en terre est la mise à
jour régulière des bases et ce à un coût
administratif exorbitants alors on a
essayé de le faire à plusieurs reprises
et puis finalement on y est enfin parce
que on politiquement en plus c'est très
compliqué alors la loi de finances pour
2020 a prévu une réévaluation des bases
qui devrait s'étaler en 2023 et 2026
j'ai quelques doutes que parce que c'est
très long 1 à l'échelle d'un
gouvernement
j'ai quelques doutes que celle de cette
réforme
cette énième réforme de l'évaluation des
bases à l'egypte a accusé à plusieurs
reprises notamment sur les perdants et
les gagnants
vous vous estimez perdant vous en tant
que maire d'une commune
à vrai dire je suis assez inquiet parce
que comme le disait françois baroin qui
est président de l'association des
maires de france
le président de la république à
supprimer un impôt qui ne lui
appartenait pas et c'est vrai que
c'était dans son programme électoral
donc c'est tout à son honneur aussi
d'appliquer une promesse qui était la
sienne
malgré tout en tant qu'élu local et
c'est vrai depuis des années et madame
aussi pourra pour faire le
l'historique de la suppression des taxes
d'habitation et taxe foncière et taxe
d'habitation pour la région ont été
supprimés en 2000 pour le département en
2011 comme la taxe foncière ce pour la
région ont été supprimés également en
2011 donc depuis 20 ou 30 ans on a quand
même une accélération de la perte de
l'autonomie financière des collectivités
qui pourtant garanti dans la
constitution de la révision
constitutionnelle de 2003 mais en tant
que maire moi je suis assez inquiet
parce que aujourd'hui on vient
quelque part nous prendre la possibilité
de lever un impôt qui nous permettait
d'assurer aussi des services publics de
qualité
aujourd'hui on le sait que de toute
façon c'est inéquitable madame la très
bien rappelé on supprime une taxe
d'habitation mais on va réviser les
valeurs locatives juste d'ici 2026 il
faut espérer que ça aille à son terme
puisque c'est nécessaire ça a été fait
sur les locaux professionnels déjà après
pourquoi avoir supprimé une taxe
d'habitation alors qu'on va revaloriser
les bases
enfin les valeurs d'ici 2026 je me pose
déjà cette première question et la
deuxième c'est que l'autonomie que nous
avions en tant que élu local de pouvoir
lever la taxe d'habitation ça nous
permettait d'avoir une dynamique
supplémentaire parce qu'aujourd'hui il
est vrai que l'état va compenser
évidemment les bases que nous avions les
recettes fiscales que nous allons perdre
puisqu'on va récupérer une partie de la
taxe foncière du département voilà on
sera sûr compensées ou sont sous
compenser et il y aura un coefficient
correcteur
c'est justement quand on regarde la
court terme sur la commune de nos repas
les bases définitive du rapport
budgétaire de 2010 neuf sont de 37
millions oui 606 110000 euros par don
parce que j'avais le petit gars qui me
perturbait pour 2020 celles apprécié la
prévision est de 38 millions c'est une
augmentation pour vous mais vous êtes
inquiet pour l'avenir oui parce qu'en
fait quand vous regarder l'historique
depuis quelques années j'ai fait un peu
le comparatif depuis 2016 par exemple
les bases ont augmenté de 3%
l'inflation de plus de 5% et j'ai ma
dotation globale de fonctionnement
kbc de 2,3 millions soit 7 de 70%
on a des péréquations qui augmente des
dotations d'état qui baisse et là on
vient nous
rendre j'allais dire un tout qui nous
permettait j'allais dire d'être un
levier pour assurer des missions de
service public d'investir davantage de
se désendetter de recruter des
assistantes maternelles ou des
animateurs ce que j'ai des nouveaux
habitants qui arrivent également
donc en fait ce mécanisme de
compensation des bases oui il existera
mais il est tellement faible qu'il ne
pourra même pas couvrir l'ensemble des
dépenses nouvelles que j'aurai avec les
nouveaux habitants et c'est ça qui est
inquiétant et donc ce pouvoir de taux
que j'avais en tant que maire il mais
supprimée et finalement ce qui va se
passer ça va se reporter sur les
propriétaires puisque le seul taux qui
sera maintenant possible d'être levée
par les élus locaux
comme pour les intercommunalités
évidemment les communes aussi le bloc
communal ce que l'on appelle en droit
bassett la taxe foncière et donc à terme
j'ai cette crainte qui est légitime que
il y eu une explosion da taxe foncière
et je pense que si on en reparle d'ici
15 ans on verra quand on aura une
flambée les taxes foncières parce que ce
sera le seul taux que les maires
pourront lever et est également les
intercommunalités
donc on a dû faire tonner justement sur
cette explosion à cette crainte de la
taxe foncière je vois lever la main
qu'est ce que vous lirez réagir à ça est
ce que justement ce n'est pas se baser
sur une certaine partie de la population
et en oublier d'autres et notamment
scindé la population entre les
propriétaires et les locataires
déjà je voulais bien mais sinon c'est
que la taxe d'habitation pour réellement
dans la question pourquoi on en nombre
est évalué les bases alors qu'on
supprime entre guillemets la taxe
d'habitation
si con réalité elle n'est pas supprimer
cette taxe d'habitation
elle va subsister ga même que les
collectivités locales vont continuer à
voter les taux pourquoi alors pour des
raisons juridiques extrêmement complexe
que je peux pas vous expliquer ici
mais la constitution oblige à avoir une
certaine d'un certain quota de
ressources propres donc nommé moyen
qu'ont trouvé les juristes c'est de
maintenir cette taxe d'habitation et la
sphère compensés par l'état
donc en fait en 2017 tout donné il n'y a
pas de pertes financières puisque la
compensation se fait par l'état
sur des sur des grâces d'ailleurs à la
fiscalité nationale
le risque il est pas actuel le risque il
est dans le temps c'est à dire que
l'état compense au début et puis ensuite
il compense de moins en moins il ya
d'autres domaines où c'est arrivé donc
la vraie question elle est là c est ce
que dans le temps ça va perdurer cette
compensation
moi personnellement j'ai quelques doutes
alors est-ce que c'est complètement
illégitime pas forcément d'ailleurs
parce que dans un contexte de réduction
des dépenses publiques
il n'est pas passé au moment où on
demande à l'état pour respecter les
critères de maastricht de pc sont le
poids de la fiscalité les papilles
logique non plus quand on le demande
aussi aux communaux ou quand même un
petit peu relativiser il est évident il
est évident que les communes vont être
tentées j'irai à supposer que
politiquement elle fiche le faire parce
que le vrai problème est là elles vont
être tentée de reporter les les
augmentations qu'elles ne peuvent plus
faire sur la taxe d'habitation sur les
propriétaires alors ça va dépendre
ces augmentations ont d'ailleurs dépend
de la couleur police souvent mais
couleur politique des des communes parce
que une commune de droite dit de droite
va pas réagir de la même façon quelle
commune de gauche c'est plus compliqué
pour une commune de droit d'augmenter la
taxe foncière que ron commune de gauche
du point de vue purement purement et
théologique donc effectivement le risque
est là si l'état n'est pas raisonnable
et ne compense pas de tel qu'il devrait
puisque la la la constitution prévoit
une compensation
grégory vce longue et réagir notamment
en tant que maire dvd divers droite dans
les yvelines est ce que votre étiquette
aussi peut vous empêcher plus tard
d'évoluer sur les taxes n'ont pas je
suis je suis très pragmatique et
j'allais dire aujourd'hui alors je
je vais apporter une nuance le taux de
la taxe d'habitation va disparaître sur
la résidence principale
il va perdurer sur les résidences
secondaires donc on crée aussi une usine
à gaz
alors déjà que la fiscalité locale c'est
assez complexe pour nos concitoyens
mais là c'est vrai qu'on va créer deux
catégories de citoyens on n'aura que les
propriétaires qui paieront l'impôt local
et cesser aussi qui me dérange en tant
que maire c'est qu'aujourd'hui on va
voir des contribuables qui sont
propriétaires et d'autres qui jouiront
j'allais dire des services publics qui
continueront à rouler sur les routes à
avoir le cadre de vie s'améliorer avec
du fleurissement de la propreté urbaine
mais qui ne paieront plus l'impôt et
donc on va accélérer au 6e je pense ce
phénomène consumériste c'est à dire de
consommer les choses sans savoir ce
qu'elle coûte c'est pas grave c'est
l'état qui paye en gros ce qui est
exactement et ça me pose un problème
éthique ça me pose un problème
philosophique même sur le rapport à
l'impôt de nos concitoyens d'autant plus
que je crois que l'impôt local et l
impôt qui était un peu plus le plus
consentis parce qu'il y avait une vision
concrète de ce qui se passe est que
l'argent que les contribuables paient
donc on va voir cette distinction et
j'ai une autre crainte également
c'est dans la construction de logements
les villes qui n'ont pas 25 % de
logements sociaux
je rappelle que quand vous construisez
du logement social le bailleur social
est exonéré de taxes foncières entre 15
et 25 ans c'est le code général des
impôts mais en plus les habitants qui
vont arriver dans ces logements sociaux
ne paieront plus de taxe d'habitation
donc je pense que ça va également avoir
un effet pervers qui sous-estimé
aujourd'hui qui va être de freiner la
construction de logements alors qu'on en
a besoin de construire du logement de
l'accession à la propriété du locatif
qui aidera pour que nos concitoyens plus
vus se loger et aussi qu'on puisse faire
venir des familles sur le territoire
donc ça c'est une crainte je pense
qu'elle sous-estimé est également sûr
j'allais dire l'évolution des des
compensations de l'état mots si j'ai une
crainte on le voit il ya des efforts
évidemment à faire sur les économies moi
j'en ai fait j'ai fait 2 millions
d'euros d'économies depuis je suis maire
mais en même temps on m'a pris 2,3
millions de dotation globale de
fonctionnement et ça a été ma raie à
l'époque de monsieur hollande qui devait
faire un plan d'économies de 11
milliards
sur ce milliard ont déjà été engloutis
là avec ce qui se passe avec la crise
est d'autant plus que la compensation
pour l'intercommunalité de 50 en
yvelines mais aussi pour le département
qui va perdre sa taxe foncière
ce serait une fraction de la tva donc ce
sera un impôt de consommation
donc si les et français consomment moins
qu'est ce qui va se passer
est ce que l'état va baisser aussi ces
compensations un moment à un autre quel
que soit le gouvernement d'ailleurs donc
c'est vrai c'est vraiment une crainte et
on n'a pas de vision et c'est vrai qu'à
chaque fois qu'on change de gouvernement
on a une révision fiscale ça change tout
le temps on a pas de stabilité et pour
vous dire on a été assez et sort est
déjà sous le mandat de françois hollande
voilà donc ça m'inquiète vraiment on a
parlé des concitoyens ils ne sont pas
autour avec le tour de la table donc on
leur a donné la parole parce que selon
un communiqué de presse de yaël round
civique et député de la 5e
circonscription d une et présidente de
la commission des lois
sept suppressions concernent en 2020
près 2 300 mille foyers dans les
yvelines qui ont vu leur fiscalité
baissé de 675 euros
alors justin brasier et patrick jacques
de dixmude sont allés à la rencontre de
quelques saint quentinois pour connaître
leur situation et leurs sentiments à la
bc oui elle a pas été supprimée de gens
pensent que j'aurais dû normalement ne
pas avoir à repayer cette année mais
visiblement ce n'est pas le cas donc
j'ai payé même si ça a baissé j'ai quand
même payer la taxe d'habitation
elle a été supprimée en totalité et je
trouve ça excellent bon c'est vrai que
les communes ont besoin de la taxe
d'habitation pour divers projets mais en
tant que particulier c'est vrai qu'on
apprécie moi je vais payer très lourd je
suis sur la commune de bois d'arcy et
c'est vrai que
sur mon budget j'apprécie quoi la taxe
d'habitation pour moi en effet elle a
bien diminué par contre c'est la taxe
audiovisuelle qui a augmenté
bah ce que j'en pense ça fait toujours
du bien aux portefeuilles de payer moins
cher ma taxe d'habitation n'a pas baissé
encore puisque malheureusement pour moi
je fais partie des revenus élevés je
pense que c'est une bonne chose parce
qu'on paie déjà beaucoup de d'impôt sur
l'immobilier
donc ce sera une bonne chose mais je
n'ai pas encore vu sur la feuille
d'impôt la conséquence je pense que
payer moins de taxes en france et 1
passe et toujours bien donc c'est
toujours bienvenu qu'on nous laisse un
peu les taxes dans notre quotidien
pascal berteaud nous on a bien entendu
les saint quentinois sont plutôt
contents de plus payer de taxes mais on
sent qu'il ya un effet on peut permettre
à ce que ça pourrait rendre des communes
pauvres dans les années à venir
cette supra lors cette suppression même
si ce n'est pas nos alors je pense que
de toute façon c'est déjà une carte
c'est à dire que la vraie inégalité
contrairement à ce qu'on croit
c'est pas tellement ses fiefs contre les
contribuables mais c'est surtout entre
les communes il ya des mécanismes
il ya des communes riches et communes
pauvres pourquoi parce que vous avez des
communes qui sont peuplées et vous avez
des communes qui sont rurales
vous avez des communes où vous avez
beaucoup de contribution économique
territoriale c'est à dire parce qu'ils
auraient beaucoup de commerces beaucoup
d'entreprises et donc ça toute réforme
de la fiscalité locale
c'est quasiment impossible parce que que
l'on son cocon et fasse évoluer les
bases au conte qu'elle compte des
revenus ça changera rien j'ai vu que ça
accentuera les problèmes et que des
communes pauvres il y en a déjà
je suis pas persuadé que la réforme
change à changera les choses les
communes riches maisons de la ville de
paris bah oui la ville de paris à des
pots de l'imposition sur la taxe
foncière et la taxe d'habitation très
simple pourquoi parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de beaucoup de commerces dont beaucoup
de contribution économique territoriale
et ça on ne sait pas comment régler le
problème
on a depuis 40 ans on a des mécanismes
de péréquation c'est à dire on prend un
petit morceau de la taxe qu'on
redistribue au niveau départemental pour
justement régler ces points de
différence de richesse ça ne fonctionne
pas et on trouve pas la solution est
simple et complet ce qui est les
citoyens ne s'attendent peut-être pas
parce que c'est vrai qu'on peut y noter
qu'on n'a pas nécessairement vous
vérifié à quoi ça va amener mais est ce
qu'il n'ya pas aussi une volonté de
recentralisation des pouvoirs parce que
finalement les communes auront moins la
main sur leur budget oui mais je pense
que alors après c'est une question de
philosophie serre que certains sont des
adeptes de la décentralisation je dirais
même qu'ils veulent aller jusqu'à la
décentralisation fiscale ce qui quand
même pas la même chose que la
décentralisation financière
moi je suis pas une personne ayant une
grande adepte de la décentralisation
autant je pense qu'effectivement les
communes sont en soi même sont mieux à
même d'organiser les services publics
locaux mais tiny paiement de dépenses
locales veut pas forcément dire
autonomie fiscale
le vrai problème qui se pose c'est
permettre et donc une redescente rallier
une recentralisation ne me choque pas
par contre ce qui est compliqué à mettre
en oeuvre c'est la redistribution des
dotations d'état aux collectivités
locales et de façon je dirais neutre
pour réduire ces inégalités entre entre
des communes riches et communes pauvres
parce que dans des communes rurales par
exemple l on peut donc me le seul moyen
que que l'état c'est d'apporter des
subventions spécifiques mais ça va très
vite des limites on reste je vous ai vu
réagir
oui mais même être à raison parce que on
est sur un débat philosophique entre les
jacobins et les girondins j'allais dire
plus de décentralisation au moins deux
ou plus de centralisation plus plus tôt
et que aujourd'hui je rappelle que notre
république
elle est indivisible et il le fait aussi
que l'état central reprennent la main
sur la fiscalité locale quelque part
c'est de garantir aussi c'était à
uniterre pour éviter que quelque part
les collectivités locales soit
indépendante ou on finisse par être sur
un modèle plutôt de fédération par
exemple comme ça peut être le cas en
europe ou aux états unis donc mais
malgré tout l'effet pervers c'est comme
je les dis c'est l'augmentation des
tarifs c'est l'augmentation de la taxe
foncière s'est créé des catégories de
citoyens qui ne seront plus contribuer
mais des usagers et qui ne se rendront
plus compte de ce que coûte un service
public
déjà que c'est compliqué à faire
comprendre parce que la réalité du
service public et parce que ce que
payent vermand l'ailé quand les
contribuables mais c'est de rompre en
est aujourd'hui
quelque part il aurait mieux fallu
comment dire réviser en effet les
valeurs locatives comme ça va être
engagée par le parlement entre 2023 et
2026 ça a été rappelé mais que tout le
monde paye l'impôt
alors évidemment à la hauteur de ce
qu'on peut payer
mais cette justice fiscale qui
aujourd'hui va va pas exploser
complètement avec cette suppression de
taxe d'habitation alors j'entendais
évidemment nos concitoyens qui était
heureux mais moi en tant que
contribuable j'ai commencé à voir la
première partie de ma taxe d'habitation
qui est supprimée évidemment en tant que
contre les bucks content mais malgré
tout en tant que maire j'ai un
positionnement qui différent parce que
je vois comment ça se passe et l'effet
pervers c'est qu'il va falloir financer
les services publics et que la seule
j'allais dire compensation des bases ne
suffira pas dans le temps puisque
l'évolution est beaucoup plus faible que
ce que le taux nous aurait permis en
levier à un moment donné voilà sur sur
un mandat ou sur ou sur plusieurs pour
financer des services publics parce
qu'on n'augmente pas les tours par
plaisir au nom des taux parce qu'on
investit parce que on recrute davantage
parce qu'il ya des nouveaux habitants
aussi qui arrivent parce que on a en se
désendette voilà il ya plein de raisons
pour lesquelles il y avait besoin de cet
honneur
autonomie et tu m as raison également on
est devenue financière est pas une
autonomie fiscale
ça s'est rappelée dans là dedans la
constitution également voilà donc c'est
assez inquiétant d'autant plus que comme
ça change à chaque fois que
on a un gouvernement différent donc on
sait pas comment cette compensation va
durer dans le temps n'a pas de
visibilité et aujourd'hui je peux vous
dire qu'avec la baisse de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement qui a été
créée en 79 justement pour aussi
compenser des compétences transférées
auprès des collectivités territoriales
l'exemple de maurepas en 2014 3 millions
d'euros on n'est plus qu'à cinq cent
mille euros et j'ai une projection en
2023 à être à -400 donc je serai
redevable de 400000 euros par an à
l'étincelle fois ci plus les fonds de
péréquation qui augmente et auprès de
l'agglomération c'est la même chose va
participer aux effets de péréquation
donc aujourd'hui on nous prend de plus
en plus de recettes
on a moins en moins dynamique mais
l'inflation est importante également et
on a le coût des services publics qui
augmentent également
donc voilà c'est c'est un exercice qui
va être difficile et on a besoin de
visibilité d'être assurée et là
aujourd'hui je pense que les cours nos
concitoyens vont être contents pendant
un temps mais pour les propriétaires ont
je pense qu'on en reparlera d'ici une
dizaine d'années et ce sera une autre
histoire
mais pascal berthenet j'aimerais qu'on
termine avec vous vous le disiez pour le
moment on ne trouve pas de solution elle
ne serait pas réformable cette taxe est
ce que les chercheurs notamment eelv est
ce qu ont des pistes des idées ou
vraiment on restera sur quelque chose
peut-être sans solution alors je dirais
que moi si les hommes politiques je fais
pas partie des gens qui pensent que les
hommes politiques sont incompétents donc
je pense que si c'était simple la
solution aurait été trouvée depuis très
longtemps que ce soit au niveau de
l'état quel que soit le gouvernement
d'ailleurs c'est compliqué parce que
alors je voulais juste dire c'est des
connexions entre l'usagé du service
public et la perception de l'impôt ça
existe ça existe aussi au niveau de
l'est parce qu'il ya des gens qui payent
actuellement quasiment aucun impôt sauf
à tva parce que la voir si son choix et
donc ils ceux qui perçoivent plus les
services auxquels ils ont droit donc ça
c'est que ça n'est pas spécifique à la
fiscalité locale
je suis pas très optimiste sur sur la
réforme fiscale moi je
je ne crois pas à l'évolution de la
fiscalité locale en fonction de revenus
même si ça a l'air d'être une bonne idée
c'est une fausse bonne idée parce que ça
va accentuer les inégalités entre les
collectivités locales et que les
communes riches sont encore plus riches
parce qu'on sait aussi que la
concentration des ressources elle
finalement elle est encore pire que la
concentration des patrimoines le calme
toi
donc moi l'art de la recentralisation ne
me choque pas à une seule condition
c'est que l'état ne recentralise pas les
recettes et qu'il continue à
décentraliser les dépenses parce que le
problème c'est qu'il faut que l'état
soit de bonne foi ce qui n'est pas
toujours
donc la seule solution à mon avis c'est
un dialogue de bonne volonté entre
l'état des deux côtés d'ailleurs entre
l'état et les collectivités locales
l'état prenant conscience que les
collectivités locales ont des
contraintes et les collectivités locales
prenant conscience qu effectivement on
l'éteint ne peut pas indéfiniment france
financer tous et d'abord devoir est
certes très compétitif et on est pris
par le temps monsieur gasté voulait
aussi réagir mais malheureusement je
dois rendre l'antenne mercier tous les
deux d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
nom se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]